[Music]
foreign
was a bad idea but the other character
Zhu Ming Resorts by saying that he has
been raising and trading it since it was
a pub so this is the fourth Mega first
trailer this one is no joke either it is
massive in size and looks to be somewhat
not really that aggressive towards
zooming as you would normally see sharks
in real life not attacking divers but
tending to avoid them then there is a
split scene where it seems like the
shark ate the guy this would seem so but
remember that this is the main
supporting character and he did appear
in the last scene of the trailer saying
that was exciting meaning the scene was
meant to throw the viewers of God and
think that it's just one of the three
Megs but nopes that's a new one maybe
even a good guy
now it's just the baby Meg from the
first movie as the old man from the
movie iRobot said now this is the right
question
so in the first Mech movie when Jonas
managed to kill a large female in the
end there was a feast for other sharks
they came in from all directions in a
feeling frenzy akin to piranhas but
among the many different specimens of
white and hammerhead sharks there was
one that struck out it was a baby
Megalodon that even in its baby form was
equal in size to the adult individuals
of the other species now this plot was
left in the Deep literally but the novel
gives us another Insight it says that
when Jonas managed to kill the gigantic
creature prior to its demise the mech
gave birth to a baby shark named Angel
as the story progressed Angel eventually
became a mother of two other pups named
Lizzy and Bella in the subsequent novels
and I'm pretty sure that this Meg that
was raised by these humans in the movie
is either angel or one of her pups yeah
Angel is described as an antagonist but
there might be changes in the movie
adaptation
so in the mind Q business we ask only
one question first how big is it if the
shock is indeed Angel and she is as the
novel dictates inside that is she would
be in excess of 82 feet long or more
than 24 meters but that's just the books
in the live action movies we tend to
demand an exaggeration especially for
shock and awe but I'm betting that this
shop would definitely be more than 100
feet or maybe around 120 so between 30
and 36 meters long so how big will it be
compared to the other three Megs taking
note from the previous video we made on
estimating the sizes of the three
shelves we get a series of measurements
the smallest is around 60 feet or 18
meters the middle one is as big as the
second Mech from the first movie around
30 meters or 100 feet long and yeah the
biggest would be around 170 to 180 feet
so around 55 meters long therefore Angel
here are one of her pubs would be
between the sizes of the biggest and the
second biggest among three it would
definitely be a Powerhouse here in the
movie
now is it the one fighting the Kraken in
the trailer well yeah I hope so it
should act as a counterweight to not
just the Kraken but also three other
Megs if you haven't seen a teaser then
you should there was a scene where a
Megalodon fought the gigantic cephalopod
which we shelved up as the Kraken there
were only a couple of quick scenes but
even in it the fight was on equal
grounds both creatures were struggling
to be on top and it was chaotic for one
the Kraken has numerous tentacles that
can grasp a Shop's body staying in place
with its suction cups the Kraken was
also of a similar size maybe as big as
the Maya Squid from Skull Island the
mech however has a very durable exterior
comparing to the Kraken it also has
massively overpowered musculature and a
deadly mouth full of really really
powerful teeth if the shark gets one
bite on the head of the crack and then
it's all over what if the Kraken manages
to wrap itself up around the shop then
it could potentially sink it and sharks
would actually suffocate to death in
such a case their gills need constant
movement in order to absorb the oxygen
dissolve in the sea water
so the last question will be what is its
relationship with the other Megs will it
join their pack or will it fight the
biggest one for dominance well the movie
states that the Megs were packed Hunters
which is maybe 50 correct realistically
sharks do hot in groups from time to
time but to classify them as a back
behavior is still far from real fact due
to it cause it gives them a bigger
chance to catch prey but that's just
about it a pack is something else there
is a hierarchical power structure and
social interactions anyway if Angel
meets the three Megs what will happen
let's do this in three scenario cases
the first one they welcome her into the
bag strange but possible since she is
also a Megalodon shark and probably from
a similar lineage since they all came
from the trench well maybe not Angel but
her mother this will create for the
chaos all over the world
scenario number two they reject her from
the pack how did they do it well either
they chase her away with a group attack
or they rip her to shreds preserving the
tight family bomb between the three
sharks and scenario number three Angel
gets chased away but is determined to be
the alpha predator and therefore she
kills the smallest one first then swims
away without much of a struggle then it
will fight a long hard battle against
the second one which is a bit smaller
than her and finally with some help from
Jonas or juming they both overcome the
biggest of the three leaving Angel free
in the wild as the top predator and
maybe the next antagonist
so that's all that's all about the
fourth Megalodon shark the new one that
was seen in the Meg 2 trailer anyway I
hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash the
Bell icon for regular updates and new
videos here on this channel take care
fam